hi i'm stephen wolfram and i'd like to
show you a bit about our Wolfram
language you know I've been working
towards what's now the Wolfram language
for about 30 years and big parts of it
I've been able to incubate in
Mathematica and Wolfram Alpha but it's
only in recent times that we finally had
what we need to create the whole Wolfram
language and to set up mechanisms to
deploy it very widely we're actually at
an incredibly exciting point right now
where we're suddenly able to take
computation to a whole new level and in
effect
inject sophisticated computation into
everything so what is the Wolfram
language well the first thing to say is
that it's a new kind of thing it's what
I call a knowledge-based language it's a
language where a vast amount of
knowledge about how to do computations
and about the world is built right into
the language so right within the
language there are primitives for
processing images or laying out networks
or looking up stock prices or creating
interfaces or solving optimization
problems or whatever and through the
symbolic structure of the language
they're all set up to work together in a
wonderfully coherent way let me show you
one of the great things about the
Wolfram language is that if you want to
you can use it completely interactively
even on the web so you can type
something in and immediately get a
result out like this or like this
yes it's fast of course it knows how to
factor that number two it's got all the
fancy algorithms built right in it's
also got immediate visualization it also
knows right off the bat like how to get
your friend Network from Facebook it
lays out the network automatically and
it knows all the fancy graph theory
algorithms so you can immediately ask it
all kinds of things about the network
like how do your friends break into
groups or what's the most connections
any friend has the Wolfram language
knows how to do lots of things like
let's ask it to get the current image
from my computer's camera
ah that's me well let's like edge detect
me I can have it be dynamic - I can do
all kinds of computations like there's
me broken into little squares and
there's me with a random color blended
into each square and now reassembled the
orphan language doesn't just know about
algorithms and computations it also
knows about the world
like let's ask it when the Sun will set
today there's the answer for my current
location there's the time from sunrise
to sunset in days we can convert it to
minutes
you know the Wolfram language has a
precise way of talking about everything
but when we're dealing with the world at
large we often just want to use natural
language to describe what we're talking
about and thanks to all from alpha we
built a big stack of technology for
doing that like we can just ask for
countries in South America and our
natural language understanding system
can figure out what that means and
generate precise Wolfram language code
from it so that we get a list of the
countries and now we can compute from
that like let's generate their flags or
let's find the dominant colors in those
flags well let's have a whole little
program to make a table of countries in
their dominant flag colors okay let's
try something more ambitious let's get a
list of the capitals of the countries in
Western Europe now let's find what order
we'd have to visit these in to have the
shortest tour of all of them needless to
say the Wolfram language has the best
known algorithms for solving a so called
Traveling Salesman problem like that now
let's plot the tour on a map as a thick
red line and yes the Wolfram language
has detailed maps of everywhere built in
okay well I've been doing different
kinds of examples there's really a huge
amount built into the Wolfram language
you can get a sense of it here thousands
of algorithmic functions thousands of
domains of data and knowledge but in a
sense that's just the beginning because
there's so much more power from being
able to put all these things together
and what makes that possible is the
structure of the Wolfram language and
the principles that it's built on the
first really critical thing to
understand about the Wolfram language is
that it's symbolic if you have X you
don't have to give it a value you can
just have it be symbolic X you can type
in a formula involving X and then you
can do a computation on the formula
symbolically and of course this is great
for math but one of the big discoveries
of the Wolfram language is that it gives
you a way to do a zillion other things
too let's say you've got some data with
a part you don't know
you can just treat it symbolically what
about something like a network well on
the Wolfram language it's a symbolic
expression too that displays as a graph
but you can go ahead and manipulate it
symbolically - same with 3d graphics go
ahead and create a symbolic form render
it as 3d graphics now because everything
is symbolic I can just pick up this
output and say feed it into an image
processing algorithm or I can make a
table of rotated versions of the image
something else that's a symbolic
expression of the world from language is
a user interface element like a slider I
can make a whole grid of them build up
any user interface all just represented
by a symbolic expression same with
documents and document elements - all
just symbolic
and once things are symbolic it's easy
to do meta operations on them like take
a plot and effectively just pick it up
and make a dynamic version of it
you can make a dynamic version of
anything and because everything is a
symbolic expression it all just works
you know any function can be treated
symbolically here's just F symbolic F
and actually underneath the full form of
everything in the language is like this
just a bunch of symbolic functions
representing formulas or datasets or
documents or cities or whatever so what
can you do with these symbolic functions
well one thing is incredibly powerful
functional programming neste functions
symbolically or put more and more frames
around something or make a kind of
nested interface
okay here's something more ambitious
let's use functional programming to do
some web crawling the Wolfram language
already knows how to import lots of
things like hyperlinks from my website
it's a little more code but let's nested
lis crawl out a couple of levels that
make a graph of what that corner of the
web looks like you know you can make
symbolic pure functions to do all sorts
of things like this takes the list of
English words that are built into the
world from language and creates a
function to find which one is nearest to
a given word now you can pick up this
function and apply it to any word and
make a simple spell corrector pure
functions and functional programming get
in everywhere here's selecting
palindrome words based on a simple
symbolic pure function you can
generalize this dramatically and for
example get a shockingly powerful
symbolic way to query databases and
large hierarchical collections of data
in a sense the Wolfram language is kind
of the ultimate fusion language because
it's symbolic nature lets it encompass
pretty much any style of programming one
that's very powerful and kind of
uniquely symbolic is pattern based
programming
the idea is you give a pattern for
transforming some class of symbolic
expressions like this says that anytime
there's F of some particular nested list
structure here's the value so now if we
give F this kind of structure it'll
produce a result but if the pattern
doesn't match it'll just stay symbolic
and this is basically how all function
definitions in the Wolfram language work
the Wolfram language is a huge language
by far the largest ever but it's built
on a small set of powerful principles
the first is coherence the idea that
everything in the language must fit
together I must say that I've spent a
fair fraction of the past 30 years
working to make this happen
designing every corner of the language
so it's as consistent and unified and
integrated as possible so it's easy to
understand and so one can take something
from over here and be confident that
it'll feed right into something over
there
I've had another principle to maximum
automation the idea that the language
should take care of as much as possible
let's say you're doing machine learning
and you want to build a data classifier
well there are all sorts of methods for
doing that but in the world from
language there's just one super function
classify that's packed with meta
algorithms to automatically figure out
what to do of course if you want you can
go in and control every detail but
otherwise you can just treat it like a
black box one of thousands of super
functions and the world from language
that effectively give you the highest
possible level building blocks for
programs and these building blocks don't
just contain algorithms
they've got knowledge and data to
knowledge about how to import and export
hundreds of formats knowledge about how
to interact with all sorts of external
api's knowledge about how to compute
properties of systems in the world and
also huge amounts of curated computable
data stored in the world from cloud and
continuously updated the same data that
powers Wolfram Alpha completely
programmatically accessible but ok so
the Wolfram language makes it really
easy to create really powerful programs
but what can you do with them well it
turns out that the symbolic nature of
the language does something great here
too because it lets the language define
and describe its own deployment let's
say you set up a function in the Wolfram
language you can run it in a notebook
session or you can just take the
symbolic code and deploy it to the cloud
you can just go to the cloud object from
the web and if you do you'll see a web
interface which automatically runs your
Wolfram language code in the cloud and
by the way you can set up a mobile app
to do the same kind of thing the
interface here uses CDF our computable
document format running in the cloud and
in fact you can run the whole native
notebook interface for the Wolfram
language in the cloud here it is you can
use notebooks as templates for reports
that get filled in by running Wolfram
language code you can schedule often
language code to run on cloud servers at
particular time say sending you mail you
can take any Wolfram language function
and set up an instant API for it that
you can call from anywhere on the web
like this asks for a JSON output of some
weather data for the users geolocation
if you have an embedded Wolfram engine
you can get code to embed a call to this
in lots of languages and you can
actually call the code without even
going to the web one thing about the
Wolfram language is that it's completely
scalable you can write tiny one-line
programs that are already very powerful
or you can write multi million line
programs like Wolfram Alpha
it's so much easier to build and debug
symbolic programs because at every stage
every piece is meaningful and depending
on your style of programming there are
various IDE s for the Wolfram language
that take advantage of the symbolic
character of the language you can use
the Wolfram language for
high-performance computing - it's got
parallelism built right into the
language so this is automatically
starting up and running lots of
different processes across my little
heterogeneous network and collecting the
results you can also use the Wolfram
language on the upcoming generation of
tiny embedded processors and for example
it's included with the OS for the
Raspberry Pi Linux computer you can use
the Wolfram language to interact with
devices in fact the Wolfram language is
in a unique position with respect to
devices and with respect to real-world
data in general because in a sense it's
a language that has a model of the world
built in and in fact wdf the Wolfram
data framework encapsulate that model
and within the Wolfram language there
are lots of ways of taking unstructured
data and getting it into wdf with its
units and dates and entities and so on
made canonical when it comes to devices
the Wolfram connected devices project is
curating them to make them automatically
accessible from within the language ok
so I've tried to give some indication of
what the Wolfram language is about so
how can you get started like after every
output there's a suggestions bar that
suggests what you might want to do next
and you can even try just giving input
in natural language and starting to
construct your programs that way and
when you've got a program you like you
can deploy it in all sorts of ways my
goal with the Wolfram language has been
to encapsulate as much computational
knowledge as possible so people can go
from ideas to deployed products as
quickly and easily as possible
I've also been very pleased that the
Wolfram language seems to be uniquely
good as a first programming language
because you can do so much so easily and
quickly get exposed to such a broad
range of methods and topics I've been
working towards the Wolfram language for
30 years we laid strong foundations very
early and we've just kept on building
and actually I keep on being amazed at
what's possible and now we've got a vast
stack of technology and content that I
think just completely changes how we
should think about programming I get a
big kick out of using it every day I
hope you'll have a chance
to try it and that you'll end up doing
amazing things with the well firm
language thanks very much